relative to other people somebody with
an iq score of 140 is in the upper less
than one percent
whereas uh somebody with an iq of 70 is
two standard deviations below the mean
that's that's that's a different
percentile so it's similar to like in
chess you have an elo rating that's
designed to
rank order
people
uh so you can't say it's twice
one person if if your yield rating is
twice
another person i don't think you're
twice as good at chess
it's not stable in that way but because
it's very difficult to do these kinds of
comparisons
but
uh
so what can we say about the number
itself
uh is that stable
across tests and so on or no there are a
number of statistical properties of any
test they're called psychometric
properties you have validity you have
reliability
reliability there are many different
kinds of reliability they all
essentially measure stability
and iq tests are stable within an
individual there are some longitudinal
studies where
children were measured at age 11 and
again when they were 70 years old and
the two iq scores are highly correlated
with each other this comes from a
fascinating study from scotland
in the 1930s some researchers decided to
get an iq test on every single child age
11 in the whole country
and they did
and those records
were discovered in an old storeroom at
the university of edinburgh
by a friend of mine ian deary who
found the records
digitized them
and has done a lot of research on
the people who are still alive today
from that original study including brain
imaging research by the way really it's
a fascinating group of
of people who were who were studied
not to get ahead of the story but one of
the most interesting things they found
is a very strong relationship between iq
measured at age 11
and mortality
so that
you know
in the
70 years later
they looked at the survival rates and
they could get death records from
everybody and scotland has universal
health care for everybody and it turned
out if you divide the people by their
age 11 iq score into quartiles
and then look at how many people are
alive
70 years later
the
i know this is in the book they have the
graph in the book
but there are essentially twice as many
people alive in the highest iq quartile
than in the lowest iq quartile true in
men and women
um interesting
so it makes a big difference now why
this is the case
is not so clear
since everyone had access to health care
you